welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss in dune is director denny
villeneuve's take on frank herbert's
sci-fi masterpiece that george lucas
must have read and be like oh people
like this a lot more if i just call it
star wars
and then a generation from now everyone
will hate it and then the generation
after that i want to like it again but
then
really hate it david lynch also gave it
a shot in 84 but now hopefully in
december 2020 timothy chalamet will pout
so hard at some sandy booty holes i
don't like sand
it's coarse and rough and irritating and
it gets
everywhere girl that's a booty house
after i properly
reacted to this trailer when it came out
i am now
going to break it down shot by shot for
all the hidden visual details that you
might have missed and explanations of
what we are looking at spoiler warning
because i will talk about the dune story
from the novel but i am gonna try to
avoid predicting step by step the plot
of this
movie version of it let's get started
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
okay let's start with a quick overview
as possible as that is with dune
dune is set about 20 000 years in the
future in which mankind has spread out
to thousands of planets all governed by
the feudal imperium
overseeing noble ruling families timothy
charlemay plays paul atreides son of
duke lato atreides who begins this story
ruling the planet caliban but is
assigned
to take over arrakis aka dune a desert
planet home to these giant sand worms
and the only place in the known universe
that produces a critical resource
called melange aka spice the term that
george lucas also lifted as a word for
drugs in the star wars universe but yeah
in dune spice
is the drug that people get insanely
addicted to it enhances their abilities
and elongates their lifespans
most importantly it is fed to guild
navigators humanoid
mutants who use the spice to perform
complex mental computations
in order to fold space and make
interplanetary travel and commerce
possible
you could look at spice as kind of the
fossil fuel or the gold that makes this
galaxy go round
that's why arrakis is so important now
when you use melange it causes your eyes
to glow blue
as paul sees in his vision of chani
played by zendaya
shani is a fremen a desert tribe on
arrakis
his visions of her are the result of
selective breeding by his mother
lady jessica part of a group of witches
called the bini jesuit who planned to
produce a mentally enhanced female heir
from house atreides to marry the male
heir from the rival house
harkonnen with those two's child being a
chosen one messiah to end the conflict
and lead mankind on the golden path
now house harkin are the previous rulers
of arrakis who are technically involved
in a secret plot
with the emperor to kill off house
atreides on arrakis because house of
tradies is getting a little too popular
for the emperor's
taste that is the death trap referred to
later in this trailer and
the crusade referred to in this clip now
book readers might grumble at the word
crusade because in herbert's book the
term
used is jihad as many of herbert's terms
and names
are inspired by the arabic language and
culture to be fair herbert did also
sometimes use the word crusade in his
book
either way it's a holy war but in name
only
because these warring parties are really
more motivated by power than they are by
religious differences
on to the next part of the trailer do
you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them yes the test is
simple
remove your hand from the box and you
die
what's in the box pain
here we see paul's a test with the benny
jesserit reverend mother
this is the test of humanity used by the
bendy gesture to make sure the subject's
awareness
is stronger than their instincts the
needle she holds to his neck is the
poisoned gomja bar
the test subject's awareness of the
needle must override their instincts to
pull their hand out of the box a box
that delivers a tremendous amount of
pain
because major character severed head is
inside that box painting your fingers
what's in the [ __ ] box
i'm kidding do not joke about what's in
the box being a seven reference
because quite a few humorless dune heads
in your reaction video comments will not
get the joke moving on you inherit too
much power
you have proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learned paul
walks the beaches of his home world
kaladin on their final days before
leaving for arrakis and he trains with
gurney halleck the weapons master of
house of tradies you can see shield
generators on their hands projecting
these pulsating shields over their
bodies
these shields have resonating
frequencies that protect you from
blaster fire or swift blows but
slowly moving weapons can still
penetrate it because you need things
like oxygen to be able to get in and out
and if you
shoot them at the right place it
detonates a nuclear explosion so they're
kind of handy just
also kind of dangerous and also explains
why they're using melee weapons here but
also
unfortunately when they go to arrakis
those frequencies attract
the sand worms like a magnet it's
interesting how each of the blows are
casting blue or red red maybe being for
killing blows or blows to vital organs
blows that breaks through the shield we
also see a historical carving showing
house of trades
taming a bull with runic letters on the
frame this movie is using game of
thrones language creator david peterson
to develop original languages for this
film
i'm assuming arabic will inspire a lot
of what we hear on arrakis moving on
father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one you'll lose
that one too
okay we get more of this transition from
kaladan to arrakis i love this blinding
light cast on the arriving family here
reminds me of ryan johnson's photography
in the last jedi or villeneuve's own
photography in arrival
and more of this transition in the next
clip
arrakis is a death
[Applause]
kill trap this is an extermination
okay so their arrakis arrival is met
with the sand crawlers similar to the
jawa sandcrawlers and star wars but
really it's the other way around george
lucas and ralph mccrory's designs were
inspired by herbert's descriptions in
dune
and we meet house atreides swordmaster
duncan idaho
as well as fremen tribe leader stilgar
who wears a nose tube that connects to
his still suit still suits are designed
to preserve the body's moisture
using various moisture secretions and
pumping it back into drinkable water
wear one of these you can stay alive in
the desert for weeks gotta drink your
own piss
and we meet the dark forces of house
harkenin including baron harkin himself
and his nephew glosu robin actually
behind the burning palm trees during the
conquest of atreides you can see those
soldiers lining up
and marching atreides pows there's also
a quick shot of dr wellington ua
a physician for house atreides onarakis
with suit imperial conditioning
meaning he literally can do no harm but
he does end up playing a crucial role in
the harkening atreides conflict also
serving these noble houses
are mentats essentially human computers
since all computer technology robots ai
thinking machines were destroyed and
prohibited and the butlerian jihad
thousands of years earlier which is why
all the technology we see in this movie
is super mechanical medieval old school
but before i continue thanks to bang
energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
it's sugar-free and has zero calories
yet it tastes
great there's over 20 different flavors
to choose from one of those flavors is
black cherry vanilla
my favorite flavor if you love cherry if
you love vanilla and
you have a darkness inside your soul
this is the drink for you
because it'll totally energize that emo
side of you
check out bang on instagram you can get
25 off your order when you go to
bangenergy.com and use the code new
rockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors you can also
get clothing fitness supplements all
kinds of stuff to be your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
newrockstars25
moving on they're picking my family off
one by one
let's fight my demons
okay so floating down are these white
uniform soldiers
these could be harkonnen's troops or the
sardakar
the ruthless elite military force of the
emperor whom he provides to assist
harkening
we get more awesome battle shots with
duncan notice how he slowly runs that
blade along the neck
breaking through the shield because
again slow gestures are able to
penetrate those shields it actually has
inspired an entire new
fighting style that people in this world
use moving on an animal caught in a trap
will nor off its own leg to escape
what will you do
[Music]
i know you okay here paul finally meets
his love interest
johnny recognizing her from his dreams
now here her eyes glow blue for the
melange but only suddenly
more grounded reality than what we see
in his visions and yes no one is
bothered by the fact that they are all
swimming in their own piss in those
still suits
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
over all this great battle imagery the
music we hear is pink floyd's eclipse
it's the final tract of the dark side of
the moon
and the lyrics paint this picture of the
totality of one's life experience
all that you touch and all that you see
is all part of a cosmic ballet or as the
song ends with
and everything under the sun is in tune
but the sun is eclipsed by the moon
meaning that zen balance that we're all
seeking is within reach it's just
currently blocked by this darkness that
eclipses all of our souls at this moment
it's a real
psychedelic idea really if you think
about it reflecting the spice trip
that this movie will be also sampling
pink floyd here could be a reference to
the alejandra jodorowsky's epic failed
attempt to adapt dune in the mid 70s
when he
tried to get pink floyd to do the score
for that but then the whole thing fell
apart
this is all explored in the fascinating
documentary jodorowsky's dune
the project was considered the greatest
film never made we see someone who looks
like baron harkin and taking a melange
bath
you can see the grains of that spice on
his skin such
an insane shot to me evoking apocalypse
now
not just martin sheen rising out of the
muck but also brando's character
the bald mad tyrant and a desperate
attempt to clean the power
moving on
[Music]
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
all right here is our first brief look
at the massive sand worms of arrakis
they consume
this ship as paul and gurney look down
on it i'm assuming people they care
about are on that ship
this one appears to be way more massive
than the one we see later these things
do vary in size
let's move on to the next clip
i must not fear
[Music]
fear is the mind killer all right paul's
voice over says the quote that we
love from herbert's dune i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
which isn't quoted fully here but it
goes on to say fear is the little death
that brings
total obliteration i will face my fear i
will permit it to pass
over me and through me and when it has
gone past i will turn the inner eye
to see its path and here paul finishes
the quote
where the fear is gone
only i will remain such a great quote
that reflects the terrified but
temporary despair of being on pink
floyd's dark side of the moon
and in these shots paul seems to be
stepping up as the leader
i just hope that the whole chosen one
myth is kind of sidestepped since i
think frank herbert intended paul to be
kind of an aberration to that benny
jesuit prophecy like he was a male not
the female they intended unlike the
david lynch version that
i would say turn paul into a complete
god figure by the end of that movie
like yes dune like the star wars
mythology it inspired
is also based on joseph campbellian
monomyth and arthurian legend but the
whole chosen one narrative is just way
more complex
in frank herbert's novels and i'm hoping
that this movie reflects that complexity
but let's move on to the final shot
all right here's the trailers glory shot
the gaping mouth of the sand worm which
if you listen real closely you can hear
an inhalation
sucking sound that actually translates
to
now in past depictions of the story like
david lynch's version the sand worms had
hundreds of smaller teeth
that the fremen would whittle into
weapons here the teeth are larger
bristles
modeled on the ballene of whales
remember those and finding nemo not only
does this design detail give us an
earthbound reference point for a massive
creature it also fits with these sand
worms being more like
filter feeders just sucking in whatever
they pass through rather than you know
needing sharper predatory teeth and yes
this particular sand worm does seem a
bit smaller than other ones we've seen
maybe a baby but also there's like
something cute about it maybe not the
evil lovecraftian monster we should all
run from like in that trailer reaction
video i pointed out how this design also
gives the san more mouth and eye
shape it humanizes it in a way taking
the form of a giant eye that peers into
our souls giving us
something to connect to emotionally but
yes something also to fear because giant
eyes are also pretty scary
i am just very very excited about being
able to explore and discuss
dune more with you all so do us a favor
and subscribe to new rockstars if you
ain't already hit that notification bell
and join us on our official discord
server by supporting us on patreon at
patreon.comrockstars
follow me on instagram eaboss follow new
rockstars thanks for watching booty
holes
[Music]
foreign